hi this is sal and i'm here with jeffrey
rosen who's the head of the national
constitution center in philadelphia and
in the first video we did an overview of
article of the entire article two of the
constitution which covers the powers of
the presidency and now we're going to
jump in a little bit deeper and you know
uh jeffrey one of the things that
surprises me about article two is for a
job as important as the president it's
it's it's an
awfully short amount of text it is uh
article one defining the powers of
congress is much longer the framers were
much more concerned about tyranny and
congress than tyranny in the executive
and because there is uh so much wiggle
room in article ii
presidential practice has been really
important and obviously the most
important president in establishing that
practice was our first president george
washington
and this is this idea that because it
was short it
left out a lot of what a president maybe
could do or could not do and that's why
our first president our first president
the precedent that he set was really
important for for how people perceive
the the powers of of the president yes
he was it's a nice uh homonym he was
both the president and set this
important precedent and because the
framers knew that washington was going
to be the first president he takes
office in 1789 right when the
constitution is ratified they trusted
him to establish these precedents which
have been followed to this day
and just a little bit of historical
context the 1776 is the official
founding of the country the declaration
of independence the official start of
the revolutionary war uh although
obviously you have skirmishes before
that uh then you we have the articles of
confederation that get ratified in 1781
it was deemed that it was too weak of a
of a essentially of a confederation and
then our constitution gets ratified 1789
uh same year that washington takes
office as our first president exactly
right and
as soon as he takes office washington
faces this dilemma that's not answered
by the constitution and that's does he
recognize the french revolution who've
just killed in guillotine louis xiv so
washington has these three choices he
can stand by the monarchy and condemn
the revolution
he can recognize the french
revolutionaries as the rightful
government or he can say
you know it's not my choice and all of
our former treaties are void he consults
his cabinet and decides to recognize the
revolutionaries and that establishes the
precedent that presidents now have
unilateral power to recognize or
de-recognize foreign governments
and that's interesting because when
we're looking at section two which at
least talks something about treaties it
says that the president can
make treaties i'll underline i'll
underline this the president can make
treaties provided two-thirds of the
senators present concur it talks about
ambassadors but it doesn't talk about
the recognition of of foreign countries
and as you point out the french
revolution you know things started in
1789
as you get into the early 90s the
revolution continues and washington says
well do we do we recognize uh the
government of louis xvi that helped
america during the french revolution or
do we recognize the revolutionaries who
seem to have a lot more in common with
us in terms of their principles around
governments at least the stated ones uh
and he decides that well it's not
written in the constitution here but i'm
as president i i can make that decision
to recognize uh the revolutionaries
absolutely and uh
that leads to another series of
important questions which you just
flagged who exactly gets to negotiate
the treaties and washington has
soon after the french revolutionary
recognition he wants to negotiate a
treaty with britain it's called the j
treaty so he secretly sends governor
morris who's the framer who's most
responsible for drafting the preamble to
the constitution as an unofficial
emissary or negotiator to britain
and they negotiate the treaty and then
washington
uh designates john jay as the envoy uh
the senate doesn't endorse the
diplomatic mission jay is getting his
order straight from washington after the
deal is reached then congress after the
fact approves of washington's diplomatic
entrepreneurship so this establishes the
really important precedent that the
president can send emissaries to
negotiate treaties which are approved by
congress after the fact and that
president is seized on by president
thomas jefferson who negotiated for the
really important purchase of the
louisiana territory on the spot without
congressional approval and gets senate
approval after the fact
famously negotiated with napoleon
bonaparte because he frankly it was his
navy had been destroyed at trafalgar so
he was in no position to protect
something halfway across the world and
and you know this drove jefferson's
critics crazy because jefferson is this
big proponent uh before he becomes
president of limited presidential
authority and he becomes president and
he seems to expand it by seizing on this
treaty negotiation power that isn't
explicitly in the constitution and uh
hugely increases the land mass of the
united states
and the importance of these precedents
just to go back to section two it does
say he shall have power by and with the
advice and consent of the senate to make
treaties provided two-thirds of the
senator's present concur and your point
is is that the way it's written in
section two it's not clear whether you
need the advice and consent beforehand
or whether they just kind of approve
after the fact and washington uh and his
term was from 1789 until
1797 he assumed that no i should be able
to go and very nimbly negotiate these
things without having to involve the
entire senate and once it's negotiated i
need to go to them and get them to
approve it and jefferson who was in
power from 1801 to 1809 uh kind of
further reinforced that precedent said
hey i'm just going to negotiate this
thing and then get it approved that's
exactly right and that allows jefferson
when he gets approval for the louisiana
purchase in 1803 to get the senate to
approve the treaty and to persuade the
house to finance the legal structure for
the new territory he probably couldn't
have done that if you hadn't worked out
the negotiating details in advance
and another element that the second
paragraph here of section two talks
about is you know with the advice and
consent of the senate this this is
talked about a lot and the constitution
tries to set up the senate as as where
uh the president goes to you know
test his ideas get some
thinking
but washington also decides that well
it's not that efficient to talking to
all these elected officials maybe i'll
set my own uh body that i talk to more
frequently
that's exactly right as we talked about
before section three of the constitution
seems to say that the president can
consult
congress for advice in all sorts of
situations he can convene both houses or
uh you can adjourn them and so forth but
washington established this precedent of
using a cabinet and that's a term that
doesn't appear anywhere in the
constitution uh despite uh the part of
the constitution that also allows the
president to seek the opinions of uh
the various officers washington
informally sought his cabinets advice
and today although the cabinet meets
less frequently than it did before the
presidential cabinet or cabinet meetings
is established as a precedent in the
executive branch
yeah and then the last piece that uh you
know we this this section two also talks
about the ability of the president to
make appointments anything from uh
ambassadors other public ministers
consuls judges supreme court and other
officers united states and it also talks
about inferior officers which are more
junior officers um that some of the
presidents can do that without uh
getting approved by congress
this is also up for some interpretation
and washington's precedent is important
there as well
it is uh washington was very frustrated
by the
senate and uh basically decided to
cut it out and not to seek advice and
consent in person one account says that
when he left the senate chamber he said
he'd be damned if they ever went there
again he didn't seek the senate's
written advice before making big
decisions like treaty negotiations and
he just preferred to consult the cabinet
and that cabinet had huge and important
disagreements again we know from the
musical hamilton uh hamilton and
jefferson disagree about the
constitutionality of the bank of the
united states they both give their
opinions washington listens to both and
he sides with hamilton over jefferson
and decides to bless the
constitutionality of the bank he got
that from his cabinet and not from
congress
and then finally in this appointment you
know to what degree can the president
unilaterally
take people out of their jobs fire
people that is also left interpretation
that's right washington established the
ability for president unilaterally to
fire executive officers or executive
department heads since the senate
textually has the power to hire
department heads you could have read
article 2 to allow it to have a mirror
role in firing them as well but the
supreme court blessed this idea that the
president can dismiss uh people on his
own there was an important case called
myers against united states which said
that the vesting clause which we talked
about earlier gave the president both of
the authority to execute the law and to
remove executive officials but there are
other cases like the humphreys executor
case for 1935 which said that congress
could limit the president's ability to
remove certain commissioners but the
broad precedent that washington
establishes is that the president's
unitary authority allows him alone to
fire executive branch officials
wow fascinating well thanks so much
jeffrey this this was
super valuable thanks uh great to talk